I saw their Radiance I saw their light I
saw these photos I saw my kids burst
into the door talking about how great my
mother-in-law is and great my
father-in-law is and they are amazing
and I had missed it because I was
exhausted I was tired and so what did I
have to do I had to change the way I was
doing my life but I could only do that
not when somebody was shining a
spotlight in my eyes saying look look
how bright it is it's when I saw it in
the distance and I saw my kids waving
candles around that I thought oh I want
part of that
and it's when my wife started saying I
can't make you
better but I've got to be whole and she
went to
counseling and she started her programs
and she got a awesome group of friends
and she started writing a new book and
the whole house lit up and I wanted to
be a part of that